[Music]
so
maybe it's a
a nice little conversation for the uh
for the married men here
who uh bought rings who bought rings who
bought diamonds how was the diamond
shopping for uh your ladies cakewalk
cakewalk should i ever do well as a
cakewalk you tell me everything well i
already had paid attention over the
years like what she liked and [ __ ] the
biggest thing was like making sure i had
the size right because i forget [ __ ]
like that so i wrote it down oh yeah
cause it's [ __ ] like eight and a
quarter dollars yeah yeah
yeah
but so i i went to the jeweler right and
i
i i had my family with me which was cool
and i was like yo can you put that one
with that one and they're like yeah we
could do that so they like
like like in terms of the diamond in the
band yeah yeah you knew the design and
awesome that she liked how did you why
were you able to get that information
out that's the tough part
over the years whenever we went into
anywhere anytime we were in in any mall
and she would look at any jewelry [ __ ] i
would just pay attention to that [ __ ]
and write down my phone little notes
that's the tough part about being a dude
where you need to be able to do your own
clue scouring mm-hmm
to hit them with the [ __ ] you're gonna
be a sleuth where they go
uh yeah i mean yeah they gotta you want
that
yeah
and it works
yeah it works what did what kind of ring
did you get them
well i used a website called rare carrot
which was really
easy that sounds like a [ __ ] brand
deal right this is a brand new for what
does it do you just upload a picture of
tiff's face and they're like i don't
know what she's like no no what did that
that would have been cool no but i knew
like steve i kind of knew what kind of
cut she wanted and what kind of like
band she wanted so that was the easy
part but then it was finding the diamond
and then making sure it had all the
qualities that you would want like it
it's like there's so many [ __ ]
like different qualities that people pay
like uh and get up charged for vs1 vs2
yeah and clarity clarity
gray g great j like and it's all depends
and
no blood diamonds yeah nobody like a
diamond this small
could be
more expensive than this one because of
clarity these best
yeah the clarity the size the way the
light hits it and the way it like
refracts and all that [ __ ] but yeah it
was easy for me i uh
in the early part of our relationship
knowing when i already knew in my mind i
would do it like way early in the
relationship before she thought i would
i kept on joking about her i was like if
you [ __ ] know what you want you
better give me a pdf of that info
otherwise if i [ __ ] up it's your fault
that's what i do so i kept on i kept on
pressing this keep it romantic like one
day
she one day sends me a pdf of all the
information i'm like [ __ ] solid gold
oh she's like she sends me a pdf i'm
holding diamonds i'm sitting on this pdf
for a while until the right time right
do you renew that pdf every year so she
stays up no no no no no but here's your
interests are gonna change exactly i
finally get the ring and literally i'm
holding the ring for maybe like four
months before the right time and within
that four month period after like maybe
i had the pf for like two years ago i'm
traveling all the time so it wasn't like
the appropriate time yet and then i get
the ring i'm holding on to four months
in between that time frame she finally
goes i need to update this pdf no
whoa [ __ ] be crazy [ __ ] are nuts
dude so what did you do i [ __ ] did
not change the ring
how much different was what it was
barely well the thing is it was she
still [ __ ] loves it it's still like
almost exactly well obviously i had to
add my own flair to you she wanted a
slightly different shape
oh god i'm going to change you're like i
can't change the band i can't you know
what i mean because you got the diamond
yeah so she wanted to round her princess
or what no so i ended up getting her
pear shaped but then i think she ended
up wanting uh something just slightly
altered from that after um tear drop
yeah it's too late it's too late whose
fault is it then is it your fault for
not updating it or her fault
it's my fault wow
you're a romantic man because i love you
but regardless of that there is a man
who's been praised i'm so glad i got my
story up but keep going amanda's been
praised for his genius test on his wife
that shows that real diamonds are
actually pointless
we're going to watch this right what do
you mean what do you mean pointless you
just get cubic zirconium dude he's
talking about how like how it's all it's
all uh a big market that's suppressed
right
cubic zirconium is definitely good this
is a tick tock right here uh that you
can see where a man puts his wife to the
test on some diamond earrings where he
gives her
diamond earrings and he gives her cubic
zirconium dude [ __ ] can't [ __ ]
tell [ __ ] packaging and he goes there he
goes you get to choose which one you
want one's real one's fake the one that
you uh don't choose i'm gonna return
dude i'd be sweating i did okay oh
please please pick the cubic
nobody can it's so hard
so one of those are real and one of them
oh my god
[Music]
yeah she [ __ ] up i don't even know
what the difference is like like what
that's that's the whole concept that's
what i'm saying yeah like and that [ __ ]
is even hard to even spot like because
on every diamond there's like a bar
there's like a code that matches up with
dude you know what you do if you guys
give me a diamond and a cubic i can tell
the difference what's the difference the
shine you got to get it under a lot of
light sunlight sunlight helps a lot and
you got it and you got to put on like a
white piece of paper too you know so you
can see the difference than gundam you
can do we should just give joe two
cubics oh my god
[Laughter]
we have it we haven't kicked orders is
this one every time oh but you know how
you know how you can it's like you get
the lowest [ __ ] quality diamond
that's hard as [ __ ] to tell and then you
get that but then if it's low lit and
it's like the difference is two is that
like let's say
uh where uh ryan is and he's holding the
two up and he's like shaking him that's
how you could tell
like the
distance the diamond will like sparkle
like easier
and and and usually the way that it's
cut to like there's some good cubics out
there man i don't know man there are but
we're at the point where we're doing lab
grown diamonds and [ __ ]
well lab girl diamond's actually
different and they're expensive and if
you are holding it it's gonna pick up
your skin color that's why you need a
white piece of paper you need [ __ ]
tweezers
the amount it takes to discern one from
the other is crazy yeah which is why
like low-key i mean
what's really the difference at the end
of the day you know what i mean
one has children hands that picked it
out of a [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like
nike
yeah right that's what you want yeah
yeah
i'm so [ __ ] glad though that like um
my girls are part of uh
uh like just cost like brands designing
all that [ __ ]
because it's easy to uh
it's uh yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
i do i do see those moments they they
know the facade right so when you're
outside want rubies or some [ __ ] huh
this is the welsh side with some rubies
yeah i heard that too yeah
no i mean like it's it's well when
you're when you're behind the scenes and
you get it all it's different i think
but isn't there something to like the
ability to like it's like knowing that
if you took this to a pawn shop
somebody's like yes i agree this is
valuable versus like this is worth 35
dollars you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah but
but but right after you buy the diamond
though it loses value like crazy
new car yeah it's like it was like uh i
think we did i think we did another
article here a while back where there
was a kid in school we had like a
diamond tester machine or some [ __ ] like
that you know yeah and it's fake yeah
you started going around to all like the
teachers in the school and then like oh
it's real it's real but you'd find a
teacher and be like oh this this isn't
real and then you'd see them like
sneaking behind the door recording and
she's like calling her husband and [ __ ]
like that yelling
funny
well the concept of giving diamonds for
like wedding and all that [ __ ] is a new
idea that's a [ __ ] monopoly dude that
whole industry is where did that start
but isn't that genius the uh the diamond
industry they they market it and said
like you could look it up it's recent as
in like
you know within the past hundred years
it's like
humans weren't doing this you know yeah
not at all and there's so many diamonds
there's an abundance of diamonds in the
world they're just like monopolizing
like tires we talked about this right
yeah same [ __ ] but i think it's crazy
because like you know think about like
the pandemic and weddings in general so
many people because of the pandemic
we're like oh dude we can't host a giant
wedding so you know we'll just get
married blah blah now they're not going
to do giant ceremonies and i'm like you
[ __ ] just saved like 40 grand
yo best decision of my life you know
what i mean like that's
yeah did that yep [ __ ] i'm so jealous of
my life dude how come you want to waste
money no i'm just waiting for luna to
pop up you know
i mean if you got the money to spend and
have a good time and have a really
memorable night i think it's [ __ ]
sick yeah but most people aren't in the
position to drop 50 grand in a day or
even 20. if you start your marriage in a
debt it's pretty tough it is and most
people start life in the debt yeah
because you're already gonna have your
own like you know like trials
tribulations in the marriage and now you
add a financial stress to it it's like
what's the tribulation i don't know they
just put a total next trouser
[Laughter]
they're only together tribulation i feel
like it's like our generation and
younger they're seeing what a [ __ ] up
situation it is to so you you leave
college right and then like you have
school debt and then you get your job
but then you want to keep up because
like you have scrutiny from society like
oh what you have this nice job but you
don't have the nice car in the [ __ ]
house so people get into debt there and
then you wanna like oh well i'm gonna
start my life and i gotta get a wedding
so you [ __ ] blow money on the wedding
and even if at the cheapest what is like
a more conservative price in la for a
wedding like 20 20 20 yeah 20k
dude so like you're starting life
husband and wife
in [ __ ] hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt just so you can keep up
with appearances [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude
yeah i get it but for me it's it goes
down the same thing like it's like if i
like people look at this and they go
that is valuable like whereas and and
for me like okay so look see this this
little titanium ring i got yeah i was
telling nikki i was like
i'll buy one of these [ __ ] things on
amazon look at this [ __ ] it's 26 dollars
she gives a [ __ ] we don't have to spend
400 on one and she's like no no i want
you to get the 400 one because
you won't lose it
and i'm like that's so true because this
is the same one that i had when i got
married right and i do think about it
like oh i don't want to lose it because
it you know i mean because it's valuable
because i had it from there but also
because it was worth more i've
definitely thought about it more and
cherished it a little bit yeah yeah yeah
i just think there's something to that i
think yeah it also depends on where you
place value and stuff yeah and then i
think people can make their own
symbolism and value like it doesn't have
to be a dime like i guess the idea of
the diamond thing it's people have to
understand it it was a marketing ploy
it's not a real tradition it's something
that
the [ __ ] love valentine's day too
yeah they love that [ __ ] yeah i love it
but i but i think like things are
changing like crazy though right like
it's it's gonna change a little faster
no because i had an expensive ring too
right but then since like i work out and
stuff i got this little rubber one but
when i like really had a heart-to-heart
with geo to understand like what the
meaning because i didn't wear a wedding
ring for like maybe the first like three
years of our wedding um i didn't
understand why i thought marriage was in
the heart is my commitment to you your
commitment to me but then when she told
me what it meant to her i was like
okay so now if i like it like let's have
the training he's like so then other
[ __ ] don't look at you boy maybe but
if i put off to the side like as soon as
i'm done doing whatever i'm doing like
it i know it means something to her so
this [ __ ] seven dollar amazon
silicone ring like i i treat it as if as
my other expensive one yeah yeah i think
it's just now up to the
right
well i didn't know that
dude they have those this rubber one
there's a you pay seven bucks and it
comes with a pack of six of them
if you lose one you just keep getting
change the color yo genius gray i have
black i have green and [ __ ] and it's the
most comfortable one hey gl this this is
this is
it's sweet dude it's so comfortable i
don't even remember have it on i think
it's kind of cool though like now people
can just make up what they want like and
it's it should be your own thing like
between you and your you know lover
yeah like
why is it up to [ __ ] society to
pressure to sales
sales [ __ ] sales [ __ ] that [ __ ] sales
[ __ ] sales bro yeah it's easy
i think we're good on that
[Music]
[Music]
you